hey guys how's it going my name is
markiplier and this is just gonna be a
short little vlog you don't have a lot
to talk about what what I do have to
talk about is very important
I'm Way too energetic for this but
either way the next RPG horror game that
I'm gonna be playing as voted by you
guys when I played hello hello a very
good one was overwhelmingly corpse party
you guys love that game to death
apparently almost by a margin of 2 to 1
vs. Misao now that doesn't mean I won't
play me so I just play later and you
guys are gonna be seeing that very soon
as in tomorrow soon because I need to
prep videos for my trip to New York now
why would I be going to New York well
it's just because well here's why I'm
gonna tell you exactly tell it I'm
telling you right now I'm gonna be going
to New York to visit jontron if you
don't know jontron is you should
definitely check out his videos there's
links up all over the place I'll be here
here here here everywhere there's links
of jontron videos if you haven't seen
him before
he's an amazingly funny guy on YouTube
you should definitely check him out and
I'll be going there for about 4 days
over the weekend leaving Thursday and
then I will be coming back to Sunday and
we will be making videos hanging out
he'll be showing me New York cuz I've
never even been there so look forward to
that and a lot of tweets and whatnot
while I'm there so follow me on Twitter
if you aren't already in Facebook and
screaming fine
other than that I've had the great
benefit of being able to do a lot of
collabs with other people lately if you
haven't seen it already check out
Matthias video on the iWatch which is an
apple commercial parody that he allowed
me to be in and it's amazingly well done
it's super funny check it out if you
haven't seen it links are here here here
here here
everywhere click the links Matthias is
another cool guy he's a guy that made
the real-life minecraft video in the
let's play real life videos super funny
super talented checking out but uh other
than that I really don't have a lot to
say I just wanted to you know thank you
guys generally for all your support I
know it's been only one week since the
two year anniversary but there's been a
lot of things on my mind and you guys
have been eating up the secret minecraft
playlist oh I mean I can't even believe
how much you guys love that so just
thank you guys for your support and
watching that and I'm just I'm honored
that you guys really really enjoy even
the old stuff that I've done so maybe
I'm gonna cut in a little snippet of
something that I did a while ago oh hey
didn't notice you there walls riding my
dragon well I was super embarrassing so
thanks guys for putting up with that um
that's about it for this week also I've
been working on this jawbreaker I don't
know if you saw me holding it but I've
been slowly whittling it away it was
this bigger it only said it was the
world's largest jawbreaker and it's just
it's really hard to get through but I'm
finally defeating yourself oh dude he
loved anyway let it be said that
markiplier can fit a lot in his mouth
either way thank you guys so much for
your constant support thank you for
constantly you know giving me all this
love that you're giving me over the past
two years and just like everyone who's
been celebrating my two year anniversary
and I know a lot of people have been
going back in time watching older videos
that I've done with the highlight video
that I just released and you know the
two year anniversary just thank you guys
so much because the opportunities that
I've been given are amazing I wouldn't
be able to go to New York and visit John
John one of my favorite youtubers and
work with him and make videos with him
that's awesome
and I only have you guys to thank for
that so sincerely thanks again everybody
for
with everything you've done help me get
here and that's about it for this one so
thanks for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye Oh